south sudan the world food program has
suspended food aid to nearly a third of
the more than 6 million people with fees
there the african nation has been hit by
devastating floods and droughts with
millions on the brink of starvation the
crisis been worsened by russia's war in
ukraine which has trapped grain
shipments and ports and sent food prices
soaring as debra patters shows us the
cuts in food aid are having devastating
consequences on children in south sudan
[Applause]
there hasn't been much to sing about for
months in the village of kueri
but all that could change today a
marriage is on the cards
[Applause]
wearing a green dress and an ill-fitting
wig bride-to-be in your querthmanuan is
treated like royalty she can save this
community from starvation
but it comes at a terrible cost
the bride is a child
she is just 14 years old
two months ago newcast had a future
beyond this village she was in school
where she received not only an education
but a meal once a day and then that
school feeding scheme came to an abrupt
halt
this community has been living on water
lilies but at least kids were being fed
at school when a cash-strapped world
food program had to suspend that it
forced parents to choose between food or
education
the women wait for news nikua seems
tired and resigned to her fate
i know i'm young she says
but i want my family to survive on the
dowry they will get
under a nearby tree the men are
negotiating the bride price
her father manual
lays out his sticks each one represents
a cow
he wants 100 in exchange for his
daughter
she's a child
how does it make you feel as a father
it hurts her father says the cows we are
getting are hardly worth it
but we are afraid we don't have anything
to eat
after several hours a deal is struck
the cowbells ring but times are tough
the family is only getting 60 poorly fed
cattle but it means the 25 year old
groom gets to take nakuath home tonight
if i was 14 years old
and leaving my mom and dad
i would
find that difficult yeah no it will
never be difficult she says because i
want them to be alive
nikuas loves science
and dreams of being a doctor
but there are many ways hunger
can destroy a life
it costs just fifteen dollars a month to
feed a school child here that's the
equivalent of four to five cups of
coffee and it ensures an education the
cbs morning's debra parajuba south sudan